welcome Penn sorry if I do this video
yeah welcome we've got a rapid game
going and 15 minutes no increment car
belt orsk carbon to ask denish i played
him two times and 15 minute don't
remember that better kept if they have
had this account for quite a while yeah
what can i play here yeah the Glock
variation of the four nights that's not
a bad line at all for white I play
Bishop c5 here normally sometimes I have
played d 585 night to deform which is a
funky sideline okay Bishop c5 keeps
pieces on the board and it's not bad at
all so let's go from that one thing that
black has to be aware of here is that he
very often wants to preserve this bishop
on c5 so it's not trade it against the
night yeah night a4 we want to have
Bishop a 7 this is why I make this a six
and age 6 h-6 is not related but a six
moves okay what is he doing them see
going for night to h4 maybe I can play
94 let's do that
now the knight on c6 is quite often a
liability at some often looking at d4
and before when there is a pawn on c3
that's not yet the case but still hmm so
he doesn't mind to trade on f3 okay so
after that probably yeah Queen takes
would happen hmm yeah he threatens
Bishop takes deform so it's kind of
difficult not to take so let's do that
Queen takes otherwise he's blundering
age three yeah okay I'm going to change
okay this is simple it lost a little bit
of time but it still should be okay the
question is how does he capture I
actually like Queen takes for a form but
it's not doing that an interesting sorry
a very interesting moment there this
point capture is opening the F file and
propensity for but it makes wide
structure rather inflexible that's
important I don't like it that much but
ok we're going to see what happens I
have not cashed out yet Queen takes if
you would have taken with the Queen you
had d 4 + f4 as possible space gainers
in the center and here it's not really
clear how is going to change the central
structure taking on d5 is some yeah not
leading anywhere d 5 I don't mind really
it's not it's not so clear what you
should do he has no pawn pawn break and
upon its lever the right pronunciation
or lever lever I think well leaving
right I have to look at that hit the
pronunciation
tend to say palm break because break I
can actually pronounce yeah he's
probably viewing the position similarly
as I just described it where is White's
precise play you can of course ask black
what is your play yeah in terms of
activity there is not that much what you
can do is ok now it changes entirely
with 925 ok I'm going to take it with
the bishop I think night x is not
looking good I actually like to have an
idea in this position because it is
super closed and the nidus as usual it
should benefit from the clothes nature
of the position i can't play efore in
this in this situation I'm not sure
about this f 44 it looks like i might
win the d5 pawn but i'm not totally sold
on the idea let's say I go efore Queen
f4 night XD 5 Queen takes e4 and then
all of a sudden the long diagonal has
opened and I cannot grab only three
because Lucas on the coming on the
e-file and I'm not doing that im just
castling him
this keeps this idea in the position he
formed is now a serious idea I think
maybe I could have thought that would
have been interesting maybe I could have
played efore Queen F form and then
something like b5 trying to prevent c4
maybe yeah maybe I played this attempt
to quickly possible that's really
possible but okay I don't mind that a
lot because I have I have ideas here
that are totally okay no one threatening
to take and play Queen III for a good
end game I could have played it for
actually okay kind of weird em okay just
thinking about the move and probably
would have been good now but okay this
is also not bad at all it mean if Y
takes Queen takes I'm an excellent shape
pressurizing all those pawns III g3d
five and I'm threatening to take play
Queen III that's not so easy to combat
actually if you place ruki 1 i'll take d
4 + j corny one yeah like this getting
to looks against the Queen and this is
actually very nice for me you can take
with a sitcom which I have not yet not
really considered to be perfectly honest
I should have considered that hmm
hmm now i'm playing this in a very
superficial way actually well whatever
us vandals we can take with the sea porn
which is not mean it's not that why does
some winning or anything but I should
have considered it and I takes with the
opponent plata madly yeah this must be
good for black rally this this is Jack
this trade can almost pre-move this yeah
group yet I can't remove that I'm going
to play it anyway unless unless rupee
one is good rook be one just make some
sense actually hook be one but okay I
don't really see a good move here anyway
threatening rugby one the rooks are just
much much stronger here and also what is
important to notice that with his double
porn he has a kind of his Queen side
five against four is kind of devalued
very difficult to get any any past porn
out of that on the queenside wha in a
pure minor piece end game I have
excellent chances to get get one on the
King side yeah here rookie to is a very
straightforward way getting to the
mentioned endgame but i'm not sure that
i should do that because there are other
possibilities I can try also to invade
with the rooks yes very little in terms
of active play Quincy force is something
that is a bit actor but
now I keep this I keep the rooks here on
not playing wiki to immediately maybe it
is it is a fantastically good endgame
but I I also think that my rooks might
be very good at checking pieces rookie
one coming rook to you one coming it's
not at all not at all easy for wide to
play so he pushes this if i go here what
is his reply Queen f5 may be angling for
counter play okay I think it's actually
a good idea anyway to to get King g7 he
has Queen d2 double attacking d2 and age
6 by droopy one is counter-attacking be
too ok it's just pushing stuff they're
not what it's not worrying me very much
and maybe this is wrong but I don't fear
this a lot c6 i have b 6 or be 54 he
might take a six though okay but anyway
I'm going to invade now here and go for
luke t one trying to harmonize those
rooks on the second-ranked doubling on
the second rank would be fantastic yeah
going for b5 now he has he has Queen a3
maybe this is the the idea but I have a
hard time to believe that rookie 14
look-see to whoop Dee to that looks very
dangerous for white and it takes a while
until he has has gobbled up those pawns
okay so look you one yes look ed one so
i can take the form there's also
look-see for which is not I adds
bluntness Rukavina okay let's not go
there let's play this one keep the two
rooks connected
yes now I wanted to check before here
but maybe
mmm it is slightly risky here what I'm
doing it is slightly risky I can also
take a 4 actually i am not sure not sure
at all let's grab this first and then
see a be cake squint x gives me gives me
those checks on d 2 and so on they are
looked at you looked it to a strong
right where is he going then giving me
the bishop town isn't it jack where is
he going look King f3 rooks III looks
disastrous
no out of moves it probably has to give
up the bishop fight resign yeah or that
one yeah it also that wasn't really a
good good game at from a certain point
I'm pretty starting here the movie for
is very very interesting I thought
however that here if he goes I thought
Queen f55 is even better i thought at
forum yeah but ok i was thinking Queen
f4 this is this is also kind of awkward
because I taking is actually not great
yeah I can never take III because of
rookie he won't actually not at one
rookie one and this is has opened up his
bishop actually so not a good idea
castling is good he went c3 but now no I
should think about it at least think
about it if if all is good he has this
move that I did not appreciate very much
but it is much better than Queen afford
calluses yeah that makes you for an
attractor which it should give some
immediate benefit ruki eight is good
then he went here and now now now we
come to a situation where I'm playing
badly taking on d4 is a mistake pretty
clearly I should try to improve my
position first um maybe a queen move or
so like here Luke is seven rook aea this
kind of thing this also has this
additional idea now that this is what I
should do after the capture yes to check
with the sea pawn that is much much
better than taking with the e porn and
now I have to worry a little bit you
know I'm okay I think because he he also
has his weaknesses III and d5 a little
bit so I don't think I'm in trouble but
I should have really avoided that
computer still likes my position very
much wants to do this now it's piling up
there
maybe but really it wasn't a good idea I
was I wasn't really thinking about sea
takes d4 um and just took their far too
quickly it only took four seconds that's
bad yeah I should have should have
waited to wait it a little bit this
however is now excellent young check
it's just a matter of how you play the
components to play rook a one actually
yeah not bad at all trying to attempt
the attack there but that's not bad I'm
not giving a way of anything here I
think Queen d3 and Luke see one yeah I'm
invading with the rooks and he cannot do
very much g6 can can discuss if you want
to play this I think I can probably do
this as well but I wasn't sure about
this idea ah nice tactic night ashore
check wins check very nice so okay g6 is
then not necessary but keeps ledge
before changes seven making many combos
ESO can be satisfied rue k1 however as
stockfish suggestion not that move but
this seems to be good as well here and
now okay the comp wants to play look ed
one
hmm and then some move that's that you
don't really have a gel cave yeah of
course I get a check getting I'm getting
edged actually I'm getting a piece him
that I didn't I was just playing b5
automatically keeping keeping stuff but
it's still minus three so I didn't make
any any substantial mistake him ba is a
bit quicker but this should be ok as
well and after that rookie two strikes
but he has no no antidote against
something like that if he wants to
activate here and he's still getting hit
with this check yeah this kind of thing
is check checkmate an e-check made an
important moment is in the opening
really when we go back well this is
fairly fairly normal I think 94 might be
debatable but it's not terribly bad
let's let's look at this VM there should
be three and now i'm not taking yeah
yeah yeah i think should take with the
Queen I think this is better than taking
with a pawn taking where the pawn makes
the position a bit inflexible for him
and difficult now to get this Bishop to
life if you if you take with the Queen I
think it's more likely that you get in
both those pawn pushes so you can attack
the center not just with the deep on d4s
in the game but also with the F pawned
pushing f4 I think this is a better a
better choice and should give right a
slight advantage even when the computer
is not agreeing it says equal but I
think white should be a little bit
better here of course yeah he has some
central advantage layered say here and I
don't know look here and the Queen may
be back and then trying to try to play
maybe for F for it should be should be
slightly better for white kind of
irritated that that the compass giving
this is equal
I mean I'm not it's not like i'm shaking
here and fear but i would have said that
what should be slightly better by okay
it did not happen he took with the pawn
and this is led to this somewhat
inflexible structure i think you should
avoid 95 though trading more pieces
especially the night makes the position
more static and this is advantageous for
my for my night against this bishop okay
well thanks for watching